hi everyone my name is adrian and today
i would like to tell you how to optimize
your network inference time
with openvino toolkit
i was deep learning and computer vision
engineer for last five years and now as
a ai software evangelist i am part of a
bigger team
spread out across the world so to
together with raymond paula and joel we
are talking about open open video we are
teaching people how to use openvino
so firstly a few words about the
challenge why do you need openvino
let's assume this is you
a superhero you already trained your
great neural network
and you are sure it can save the world
but to do it you can deploy you need to
deploy it
and
what is your choice of course gpu but
wait you need only 15 frames per second
and you don't want to spend a lot of
money
so i think gpu is rather overkiller
so maybe cloud but in this case you need
to build an api
you need to rely on internet connection
and still wait some time for the results
so there is question is is there some
what if you would like to
deploy on a raspberry like device is
there something cheaper and available on
the edge
so
maybe just cpu you probably probably
have already
but running on cpu is slow almost every
deep learning engineer
yet it was but is this still a true
let's check
so if you would like to deploy your
network on the edge on your computer on
your laptop and you don't want to buy
additional gpu card and build an api i
have the solution for you
openvino openvino which is open source
toolkit for optimizing and deploying ai
inference
and openvino means open visual inference
and neural network optimization
but it's not only for computer vision
it's also for nlp audio processing time
forecasting and so on
so let's start our openvino developer
journey how to use openvino
let's
assume you have you trained your model
in one of these frameworks tensorflow
keras pytorch on nx cafe
mxnet or paddle paddle i must admit here
that we don't support pythor's directly
for now we are working on this but you
can easily port your pythons model to on
nx
so then you convert this your model to
openvino and you are able to run on
intel's hardware like cpu core atom xeon
gpu and when i say gpu i don't mean any
dish
any discrete gpu card i mean
this gpu already integrated into your
cpu like intel hd graphics into the uhd
graphics iris iris max or you can run on
vpu which means for example movidus it's
like neural compute stick 2 it's a usb
accelerator you can plug into your usb
port and you have external acceleration
so you don't need to use resources of
your cpu or gpu you can use just this
device
and to use openvino you need just three
simple
steps oh sorry i forgot to mention it
works on any operating system windows
linux max
okay let's go to the three simple steps
the first step is of course install
openvino if you would like to get
openvino scan this qr code and there is
a selector tool you can
configure your environment and you will
download for example installer but there
are many other ways to install openvino
you can use package managers like apt
from ubuntu yam from
fedora red hat santos you can install
open window using pip it's the easiest
way to instantly open window pip install
open vino pip install open vinodaf for
development package
or you can use docker or anaconda
so the first step install openvino
the next step is
use model optimizer
and model optimizer converts your model
from your framework into intermediate
representation which consists of two
files
xml with
architecture and binary file with
weights and biases
but model optimizer not only converts
your model it also performs some number
of optimizations so
there is graph pruning there is uh
fusing some operations like bachelor
into convolutions and so on
so if you would like to use model
optimizer
use mo command line tool from openvino
development package and give some
parameters like path to your model or
desired data
type
what data type can you put here
pointing point 32
floating point 16.
as i mentioned the product of
optimization step is intermediate
representation so from this
to this
much more simpler much more faster to
run the inference
but if you need even more
performance better performance you can
also use post training optimization tool
to quantize your network so just give
your intermediate representation model
plus a representative data set use post
training optimization tool and you will
get
in aid version of your quantized model
so first step install conveno second
step use model optimizer and now it's
time for the last step use openvino
runtime
import openvino
your image or any data it could be text
it could be audio it could be any data
initialize openvino
read model from
these files
compile model for the specific device in
this case cpu
get the handle to the output layer
and run the inference giving
your input and getting the output from
the output layer so in the case of image
classification
from this
to this in just seven lines of code
but there is question
what device can you put here
well we support many different intel's
hardware like
cpu core atom xeon
gpu and once again it's not any
additional discrete gpu card it's a gpu
already integrated into your cpu
myriad myriad means run on never compete
compute stick too
but you can also put here hit euro if
you would like to split your graph into
some parts and run some operations on
gpu for example and some operations on
cpu why that
because some operations could be faster
on the gpu and some of them could be
faster on cpu
what else can you put here multi multi
means copy my
model across devices to increase my
throughput so if you have
many frames per second you can schedule
some of them on gpu and some of them on
cpu
and process them in parallel so we have
higher throughput
and i think
the best device
is auto auto means you don't want
to select your device manually you don't
want to configure this device
you just put auto and auto automatically
select the bus the best device for you
based on your hints
and auto also handles the exact
logic on multiple devices so
for example auto will select cpu for you
or gpu based uh if you care about
latency or if you care about throughput
but auto has also nice
feature
let's assume that the best device in
your case is gpu
but startup time for gpu is much longer
than for cpu because you need to compile
opencl kernels and so on so what auto
does
auto firstly compile network for cpu
then run inference on cpu
meanwhile compiling and loading network
on gpu
and when gpu is ready it switches the
inference from cpu to gpu
and release resources on cpu so your
inference starts immediately
and after some time when gpu is ready it
switched to gpu to have the best
performance
we have and share more than
270 pre-trained and optimized models
like
object detection
post estimation
action recognition
[Music]
monodev estimation
ocr
so you can use for example chinese
language
and many many more so if you just start
your journey with deep learning and you
don't have your own trained model you
can use one of ours
all of them are available
on our github repository just scan qr
code to get all of them
and there was question
is running on cpu is still slow
like was before
so
to answer this question
we prepared some performance benchmarks
we selected three different networks
resnet50 for image classification
yellow v3 tiny for object detection and
deep flap with v3 for image segmentation
and we performed this uh
benchmarks on standard computer it
wasn't overclocked it wasn't uh water
cooled it's just standard computer like
yours with batch size equals one
and we measured throughput in frames per
second for floating point 32 model of
course
the best results are for
intel core i7
11 generation cpu and igpu all together
slightly worse results for igpu and cpu
are the same cpu but what's the most
important here that you don't have to
modern intel cpu even if you have
um
intel core 8th generation from
202017 which is 5 years old
you still have very good results in case
of image classification and object
detection you are better than real time
performance and when i say real time i
mean 30 frames per second
even in case of cheapest intel core i3
and
the most difficult case of image
segmentation you still have more than 15
frames per second what i think is enough
in most cases
to learn more about different models
about different devices please scan qr
code
and if you would like to benchmark your
own model you already converted to
openvino you can use benchmark amp
command line utility from open window
development package
and now it's time to run the live demo
this is one of our notebooks we have a
repository here at github so you can go
there open window open window notebooks
and you can try openvino yourself at
your local computer
so i'm going to run this
notebook
okay and explain you some code so
firstly we need to import some packages
especially openvino here
then we
need to download our model and as we
downloading this model from open model
zoo we can use omz downloader command
line tool
omg downloader is able to download any
model from openmoto zoo any of this 200
to
270 models
but we would like to download ssd light
mobile net v2 because we are going to do
object detection
then
this select this
downloaded model is
in tensorflow format as i mentioned
before we need to convert it to openvino
intermediate representation
so that's the reason we are using omz
converter ohms.converter is another
command line tool to convert your model
from open model zoo to intermediate
representation
but if you would like to convert your
model you need to use
model optimizer directly om that
converter is only for open module
models
and i specify precision here so i would
like to have floating point 16
and then
we need to initialize openvino read
model from
intermediate representation compile
model we are compiling for cpu
get input and output nodes get input
size
here
and then
we specify the classes we would like to
detect
colors for these classes
we have post-processing function to
create boxes around detected objects
with no maximum suppression to get rid
of many overwrapping entities
and draw boxes on the image
there is of course main processing
function so we are creating video player
on some source it could be webcam stream
it could be
[Music]
video file
so we are getting uh frame by frame
then we are resizing this frame to fit
neural network input size we are
creating batch size equals one
and then doing the inference with time
measurement
uh post-processing
results to get boxes draw boxes on the
image
calculating mean processing time
put the inference time on the image and
then show everything directly here in
the notebook
and it works
as you can see
the label detected is
person i think it's correct
i can of course show
something else for example cell phone
but what's important here
i think the time is most important and i
cannot see time now
it's
18 milliseconds but gives 55
frames per second and i'm just using my
cpu so i'm not not using any additional
gpu cards and object direction
better than real time but let's see
what
performance will we get if we change
just one line of code
and compile our network
for gpu this time
so i'm changing
cpu to gpu
as you can see startup time is
longer than before because we need to
compile opencl kernels
but after that
i think the performance will be better
so we had
55 frames per second
let's see
how many frames per second
we will have
now
it's
65 65 frames per second just changing
one line of code i didn't buy any
card i need any discrete gpu card i just
changed one line of code and i am using
this gpu i have in my cpu
and if you would like to try it of
course no problem if you don't have
webcam you can also run on
for example video file just put url here
and you can see the results
below okay let's go back to
uh
presentation
so demo i presented to you is available
in our open video notebooks repository
to get all these notebooks just scan qr
code and you need to
do this four steps create the
environment
clone the repository
install requirements
and launch the notebooks so after that
you can do the same
there are more than 30 different
notebooks teaching you about different
aspects of openvino so i recommend to
try
and of course new ones appear all the
time
so once again scan qr code to get this
notebooks but what if you don't want to
install anything locally for example or
you cannot install or you even you would
like to try different different intel's
hardware without buying it
you can use intel dev cloud for the edge
it's free cloud service to perform open
window experiments in jupiter lab
environment
so you can test your openvino code
across different intel's hardware
without buying it so just scan qr code
to get the free access
so my main takeaway for today
is don't just believe me
try it yourself
give it a try
clone a repository see the performance
on your
hardware
maybe it's open windows solution for
your problems maybe you wanted to deploy
on raspberry like device or you wanted
to deploy on cpu but the performance was
bad so maybe open window solves your
problem
and these are platform configurations
for performance benchmarks
if you would like to learn more just
scan qr code
these are notices and disclaimers i must
share with you
and this is all from my site thank you
if you have some questions
all right so thanks audrin for the for
the introduction of the openvino so i'm
gonna now announce some questions from
the slido
uh first one is openvino compatible with
only intel cpus and gpus
what architectures and extension does it
rely on
uh openvin also works with any
cpu because it's you know every every
cpu has the same instruction set so it
it's optimized for intel cpu but it
works for any
cpu but it doesn't work for example for
nvidia gpu
it works only for intel integrated gpus
second one does openvino provide model
monitoring and maintenance
like to take care of model data drift
or it is out of the scope here well
openvino is a framework for inference so
you know
how to increase your performance so i
think it's out of the scope
okay how does openveno compare against a
dedicated gpu and tensor rt
well
we
have some performance benchmark
internally but for now i cannot share
with you in the results unfortunately
and what are the main difference between
open vino and on nx
so on nx is
another uh framework and on an x could
be run directly in openvino because
you can port on an x model to open vno
but you can also run on x model directly
in open window without any conversion so
you don't need to use model optimizer in
this case when using when uh using on nx
model
so the difference is i think um rnx is a
format for uh
for storing uh
neural networks on the disk and openvino
is a framework to run the inference
does openvenous support custom
operations in deep learning models for
example custom layers
well you can open venus open source so
you can implement it yourself if
something is not supported uh open
window is available on our github
repository just go open window open
window toolkit open vino and then you
have source code so you can if something
is not supported you can implement it to
yourself
okay
can the optimized model be serialized
and reloaded
yes i think
i think so i think
optimize model is already like a
kind of serialized when it's on on the
disk so i think it is
i think that's all the questions from
slido so
if anyone has some questions i could
pass the mic down
so if you have questions after this talk
you can find me at linkedin you can drop
me an email and we can conversate
all right i think that's everything
thank you